on avait demandé en fait un peintre de
fait des travaux à la maison mais y
avait passé une boulot pour lui donc
demandé si on pouvait nous donner plus
de travail en même temps faisait de la
céramique
audi n'a pas de problème tu peux venir
ce week end et tu pourras faire
il est maintenant c'est impossible on
comprenait pas pourquoi
et en fait vous expliquez que comme il
faisait partie d'une caste supérieure et
pouvaient travailler de l'agression ils
n'auraient pas touché de la terre que
donc il était inimaginable face qu'ils
fassent un travail au sol
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous aviez eux-mêmes en parle peu mais
c'est une réalité d'hier entre eux en
fonction de quels critères ils vont très
rapidement identifier les avoirs ou dans
la strate sociale se trouve le 21
octobre on peut deviner un dans certains
cas ce sas devine comment par la manière
dont ils interagissent avec les
étrangers déjà les questionnements et
hippiques et je vais être par leur
prestance
on va tout de suite voir de quel milieu
social ils viennent et je n'ai n'y peu
d'ambiguïté en juin très vite et
l'amiante ils vont eux-mêmes parler par
exemple au ghana l'entrée ou aux autres
manière de leur parler qui est peut être
un peu choquant pour nous mais qui
paradoxalement attire le respect des
autres reçu comme une dynamique très
particulière les gens refusent de
s'abaisser à faire certaines tâches vont
traiter des gens qui considèrent comme
un fait réellement comme des gens
l'intérieur alors comme canadienne s'est
très c'est très choquant si on est en
train de livrer de l'équipement et que
rapidement j'ai fait exactement qui
monte en citer deux téléviseurs qu'on
avait rentré ça me semble normal je
m'assois par terre je prends un critère
je commence à lasser vraiment la panique
totale parce que je suis parterre de
chant train de démonter des boîtes avec
des ouvriers alors et c'est paradoxal
parce que certains employés vont réagir
en lançant en me disant de ne surtout
pas faire ça ils vont pas le faire eux
mêmes vont trouver quelqu'un qu'il peut
faire le travail
ça c'est vraiment fascinant alors
qu'évidemment haut niveau nous payons
c'est le travail doit être fait on le
fait j'ai le niveau la hiérarchie a pas
vraiment d'importance et gérer une
société à la canadienne jeudi en inde
c'est très compliqué parce que le
principe c'est mon bureau est ouvert du
chu le pdg de la boîte mais n'importe
qui peut rentrer on va se parler de tous
les peintres
ce qui est vraiment pas le cas dans une
société traditionnelle
[Musique]